[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'hebdo
pendant 26 minutes nous allons revenir
ensemble sur l'actualité qui a marqué
notre territoire cette semaine tout de
suite le sommaire à elancourt un campus
numérique a été inauguré ce mercredi
deux organismes proposent des formations
dans ce secteur aux tensions
objectif mieux répondre aux besoins en
recrutement des entreprises installées
sur le territoire
une trentaine d'élus des yvelines et du
val d'oise ont manifesté jeudi devant le
ministère de la transition écologique
ils protestent contre un projet de
carrière cimentière à bruille en vexin
son maire bruno caffin fera en plateau
avec nous enfin nous reviendrons sur
cette canicule qui sévit depuis le début
de la semaine
deux anniversaires également dans
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
les cinq ans de l'agencé départementale
ingénérie et les 100 ans du traité de
versailles
il y a deux ans saint quentin en
yvelines a créé son campus du numérique
aujourd'hui il poursuit son
développement puisque ce mercredi un
nouveau centre de formation a été
inauguré à elancourt
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude situé dans le quartier 17 mar
à elancourt ce campus numérique propose
quatre cursus suivi par 50 stagiaires
particularité de ces formations elles
sont accessibles à toutes et tous et
gratuites pour certains le monde se
transforme le monde change tout
s'accélère et on se rend bien compte
qu'aujourd'hui 80% des emplois qui se
créent
un rapport avec le numérique donc il
faut augmenter l'employabilité numérique
notamment des saint quentinois deux
organismes de formation ont pris
possession des lieux
il propose des parcours visant les
métiers les plus en tension dans le
secteur du numérique
tout le monde recherche des développeurs
dans des programmeurs des gens qui font
du codage donc ils sont capables de
parler la langue des machines et de leur
faire faire un peu ce qu'ils veulent
donc il ya une partie développeurs web
et une partie qui est développeur plutôt
orientée sur les données tout ce qu'on
appelle le big data et donkey et
permettent d'apprendre à manipuler ces
données à les mettre en forme et à les
utiliser pour les entreprises on est
deux acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire on est tous les deux sur des
formations gratuites
donc c'est très bien de pouvoir faire
une communauté d'apprenants un peu plus
large aussi et que les apprenants
simplon les apprenants pop school soit
ici dans les mêmes locaux puissent
pourquoi pas partagée au delà des locaux
des projets des interactions à la
prochaine rentrée ce campus numérique à
elancourt accueillera une centaine de
stagiaires
jeudi matin une trentaine d'élus du
vexin s'étaient donné rendez vous devant
le ministère de la transition écologique
à paris les raisons de cette
mobilisation un projet de carrière
cimentière à breil en excès bruno caffin
bonjour vous êtes le maire justement de
cette commune de braye en vexin vous
êtes également vice président au sein du
parc naturel régional du vexin
alors avant de parler la mobilisation
d'hier est ce que vous pouvez nous
donner un peu plus de détails sur ce
projet de carrière c'est un projet qui
remonte à plusieurs années me semble un
projet très très anciens dans la mesure
où ça fait à peu près 20 ans maintenant
qu'on parle de ce projet d'extension de
terrière si mentir sur sur notre
territoire et plus exactement sur cette
zone sang neuf qui regroupe créé 550
hectares sur trois communes
principalement brillant avec st
moyens vexin fontès un père et sailly et
d'autres c'est l'extension de la de la
carrière de guîtres en cours qui doit
alimenter par l'ensemble doit alimenter
donc ta lusine cimentière de gargenville
donc ça fait effectivement 20 ans bon
après si vous voulez pour nous une
dizaine d'années on n'a plus trop
entendu parler du projet qui c'est bon
on s'est réveillé un petit peu alors au
fil des ans l'entreprise a changé de nom
mais aujourd'hui c'est depuis 4 5 ans
italcementi puis maintenant
heidelbergcement ont repris un peu ce
dossier pour le faire avancer
puisque les ressources de guîtres en
cours s'épuisent et que donc pour faire
tourner l'usiné garçons binda cimentier
souhaitent accéder tendres donc cette
carrière
on a récemment le l'état validé le
projet 1 puisque le 18 juin un permis a
été publié au journal officiel jo
j'imagine cette mobilisation et hier
devant le ministère de la transition
écologique justement que s'est il passé
alors tout à fait donc effectivement
malgré alors bondé toutes ces années
alors qu'ils ont déjà nous nous avons
déploré depuis depuis début un manque de
concertation c'est à dire qu'on
considère qu'à aucun moment ce ce projet
n'était cocon co construit ni avec les
élus ni avec les habitants du territoire
il a été il a été imposée nous a été
imposée donc depuis le début de
depuis quatre cinq ans si vous voulez on
s'oppose à ce projet à la manière dont
il a été conçu notamment parce qu'ils
pourront rappeler qu'il est dans le
périmètre du parc naturel régional du
vexin français est tout à fait donc
c'est très compliqué parce que les
habitants de ce territoire les habitants
de ce parc ne comprennent pas qu'on
puisse faire une carrière cimentière
dans un parc naturel
en même temps c'est vrai que la zone 109
existait notamment existent dans la
charte du parc
pour autant la manière dont dans tout ça
a été conçue ne correspond pas à ce que
le parc aurait souhaité et aurait pu
exiger en matière de d'exemplarité sur
pour pour son territoire alors qu'à
donner votre mobilisation
donc on avait bien conscience si vous
voulez que
pour que notre démarche n'avait pas
changé globalement la face des choses
dans la mesure où effectivement les deux
ministres concernés monsieur des régimes
le seul maire avait donc signé l'arrêté
d'autorisation que le préfet des
yvelines a donc signé vendredi dernier
la création aidé à la création de 2,7 de
ceux de cette carrière donc on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est là notre
mobilisation était plus une protestation
pour rappeler que ce projet a vraiment
été fait sans nous et quand je dis sans
nous ces mêmes contre nous parce que
hier nous est une trentaine d'élus fin
de merde effectivement des des communes
du parc et pas seulement des communes de
l'environnement mais nous avions tous
tous émergent et dire on fait délibérer
leurs conseils municipaux le contre le
projet la communauté urbaine grand paris
seine et oise a voté contre le projet
l'ensemble des 98 élus du parc
représentant les 98 communes du parc ont
voté contre le projet et les habitants
aussi se sont tous opposés donc temps
d'une grande des grandes oppositions
plus de deux mille trois cents
signatures dans le cadre du grand débat
que le président république avait
souhaité plus de 1700 contribution dans
les enquêtes publiques des contributions
mais sérieuse jeu très argumentée pour
expliquer tous les risques de ce projet
et tout ça je dirais dans tout ça il n'y
a pas eu je veux dire pas eu d'écouté et
même une cinquantaine d'élus qui sont
dues non seulement de la vallée de la
mention mais aussi la vallée de la seine
jusqu'à des élus de poissy pour dire que
c'était c'est vraiment un sujet un sujet
très important et que on ne comprend pas
on nous n'avons pas compris pourquoi
aucun moment les élus n'ont été écouté
les prochaines les prochaines actions
qu'il y en aura d'autres s'imaginent
wiba de hyères où nous sommes nous avons
donc été reçu par un parent et
conseiller technique de monsieur de rugy
bon nous lui avons dit
après lui avoir exprimé notre
mécontentement sur la manière mais on
sait bien que tout ça
ne sert pas à grand chose en revanche
nous lui avons dit aussi que par tous
les moyens
nous attaquerons les décisions qui ont
été prises tous les moyens c'est à dire
par par le tribunaux parce que depuis le
début on sait que cette affaire sera un
moment donné juger et d'ailleurs est
encore un certain nombre de recours qui
sont qui n'ont pas été plongés au
tribunal administratif recours contre
l'arrêté de création du projet d'intérêt
général enfin du label projet d'intérêt
général donnée par le préfet il y a
quelques années tout ça n'a pas été jugé
donc ça veut dire que aujourd'hui on a
nous encore encore l'espoir de pouvoir
faire capoter ce projet qui est une qui
est un projet d'autres d'autrui
rassemblements prévus les 6 et 7 juillet
romain ternel heures salle c'est des
associations notamment la belle 3c qui
est une association extrêmement
dynamique qui travaille très
sérieusement sur sur ce projet mais
aussi sur des contre-propositions qui a
vraiment travaillé depuis le début comme
ans contre 16 ans dans cette affaire
effectivement ces jeux qui vont
organiser une manifestation sur le site
merci bons caf en tout cas pour ces
précisions sur ce dossier alors vous
restez avec nous puisque tout de suite
on passe au reste de l'actualité
[Musique]
et on prend la direction de versailles
puisque le préfet des yvelines a
présenté aujourd'hui le rapport des
services de l'état devant l'assemblée
départementale l'occasion pour les
conseillers départementaux de poser des
questions sur plusieurs thématiques le
préfet a notamment été interpellé par
nicolas danville conseiller
départemental est élue d'opposition à la
verrière une question sur la rénovation
urbaine du quartier du bois de l'étang
n'écoute le préfet jean-jacques brot il
est au micro de nicolas d'andré c'est
une décision dont je fais pas il ya
plusieurs semaines à madame le maire de
la verrière il est hors de question
d'envisager une rénovation urbaine qui
ne comporte pas des démolitions on n'est
pas dans le reee pauline âge
d'appartement on ne touche en rien à la
nature du peuplement à la nature de
l'animation de la zone en question n'est
dans la rénovation urbaine c'est quelque
chose de structurel qui implique une
part de démolition qui n'est d'ailleurs
pas majoritaire loin de là on est à un
point où la municipalité solidaire de
certains locataires refusent toute
dévolution sa classe le dossier
un parent ayant juste avant la séance
avec le préfet les conseillers
départementaux ou ont voté plusieurs
délibérations à l'ordre du jour
notamment la création d'un contrat rural
yvelines plus une mesure notamment sur
lesquels nous reviendrons dans nos
prochaines éditions
de son côté l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines tenait hier soir son
dernier conseil avant les vacances d'été
les élus ont validé les comptes
administratifs de 2018 ce conseil a
également été l'occasion de lancer une
concertation préalable pour la
restructuration du secteur de l'hyper
centre à montigny le bretonneux
cela ne vous a pas échappé les yvelines
ont eu chaud cette semaine le
thermomètre à flirter avec les 40 degrés
le niveau 3 du plan canicule a été
activé ai les maisons de retraite ont dû
notamment s'organiser afin que les
résidents ne souffre pas trop de la
chaleur est miquel et demi d'euros cn
bazire et audrey chaillou se sont rendus
dans un établissement à guyancourt
madame you est ce que vous voulez un
petit peu d'eau oui d'accord hydratation
régulière ventilateur volets baissés
cette maison de retraite de guyancourt
est passé en plan canicule depuis samedi
dernier
objectif éviter les risques liés à la
montée des températures qui atteignent
cet après midi près de 33 degrés le
matin ce que les filles elles font
savoir les aides soignantes à comment
dire pendant la toilette
elle ouvre les fenêtres en grand pour
permettre de rafraîchir les chambres
ensuite elle referme les volets une fois
que les toilettes sont finies elle
emmène les résidents dont plusieurs
pièces qui sont climatisées la
surveillance se fait 24 heures sur 24
dès les premiers signes de fatigue
l'alertent est donné quand on voit qu'un
résident un petit peu plus fatigué que
d'habitude ou agressif par rapport à
d'habitude là on commence à se poser des
questions l'essai de l'hydrater si on
voit que l'hydratation ne passe pas on
voit avec le médecin coordinateur où le
médecin traitant qui qui vient tout de
suite auprès du résident et nous dit ah
les consignes à suivre un encadrement
qui satisfait les 91 résidents présents
actuellement dans la structure pas trop
mal on s'occupe bien de nous y voilà je
suis pas seul alors c'est déjà pas mal
on peut pas l'éviter vu le temps qu'il
fait à l'extérieur non là on est bien ce
matin en me donnait improvisateurs la
douche vous l'avez tous les jours y'a
pas de problème
ce plan canicule devrait durer au
minimum jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
dans cet établissement
et rassurez vous on devrait moins
souffrir de la chaleur ces prochains
jours puisque on va perdre quelques
degrés comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces
prévisions à météo alors bruno tf1 au
niveau de votre commune commande et vous
gérez vous cette canicule
on n'a pas fait un bon petit qu'on a
pris un soin plus particulier enfin on a
fait un peu plus attention mais je crois
que c'est un sujet effectivement grave
et important pour je pense qu'on a fait
dans ce pays beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
sur ces sujets bon dans les écoles oui
on a enfin les enseignants 13
connaissent leur métier dont qu'ils ont
arrosez plus souvent les gamins par
exemple accès à l'eau etc mais mais je
crois à fermer les rideaux au fait des
choses assez basique b mais je crois
qu'après mon choix je crois que deux
dans les écoles ça pose pas un vrai
problème des enfants sans générale
solide alors une solution pour se
rafraîchir par exemple elle est l api
sienne alors un peu compliqué évidemment
à maurepas car elle est fermée depuis
mai 2015 plusieurs audits ayant confirmé
sa dangerosité
après plusieurs ruptures recours d'une
partie de l'opposition qui souhaitait
une réhabilitation et bien c'est une
déconstruction puis une reconstruction
qui se déroule actuellement puisque
mercredi
les pelleteuses sont entrées en action
fait le point tout de suite sur ce
dossier avec michael et demi d'euros
après le désamiantage place à la
déconstruction à maurepas les
pelleteuses sont maintenant à l'oeuvre
pour faire disparaître toute trace du
centre aquatique fermé depuis 2015 pour
raisons de sécurité
vous pouvez réhabiliter c'était possible
mais ça coûtait beaucoup plus cher et
c'était j'allais dire est responsable
vis-à-vis des finances publiques puisque
de toute façon on est on aurait été
obligé à chaque fois de d'entretenir de
refaire des travaux puisque vous le
voyez la structure elle est complètement
corrodé les bassins n'était plus aux
normes depuis 1981 à datant des années
70 l'équipement accueillait particuliers
associations et scolaires la tante avant
de retrouver les bassins devrait prendre
fin en 2021 alors l'avenir de ce lieu
c'est un centre aquatique qui
correspondent aux besoins des habitants
moderne beaucoup plus ludique et
familial que ce qu'on a connu auparavant
on doit avoir un projet qui dure dans le
temps pour 30 ou 40 ans avec des
matériaux qui soit durable également
puisqu'on part certainement gardé des
bassins en inox qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les basses en carrelage que nous
avons connue et qui causait pas mal de
fuite pour la déconstruction qui va se
prolonger pendant l'été 157 mille euros
ont été investis un coût partagé avec la
ville d'elancourt elancourt qui
financera aussi la construction de la
prochaine structure tout comme la région
ile de france ou encore le département
montant global 15 millions d'euros
prochaine étape donc le choix dans un
concessionnaire privé en délégation de
service public ce dernier aura un an
pour réaliser la nouvelle piscine à
noter que 80 % des déchets de ce
chantier actuel seront recyclés annonce
le maire
elle est au service de l'urbanisme
encore du patrimoine des yvelines l'
agence technique départementale
ingénierie a fêté ses cinq ans mardi
soir c'était au domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles en présence du
président du sénat gérard larcher la
structure en a profité pour mettre en
avant son bilan positif
dans quelques mois le centre du village
d alu et le roi va retrouver une seconde
jeunesse montant de ce projet plus d'un
million et demi d'euros
un chantier rendu possible grâce à
ingénierie cet organisme a été créé il
ya tout juste cinq ans par le
département des yvelines
sa mission accompagner les communes
rurales dans leurs projets de
réhabilitation de construction je crois
que le pari est réussi c'est surtout les
chiffres qui nous permettent de dire que
le pari réussi puisque plus de 90% des
communes rurales ont adhéré 170 communes
rurales ont adhéré les trois
établissements publics de coopération
interdépartementale qui ont des communes
rurales ont adhéré également depuis sa
création l'agencé a répondu à plus de
700 demandes toutes les prestations sont
gratuites
le département c'est un acteur de la
cohésion sociale tout le monde le sait
mais c'est aussi un acteur de la
cohésion territoriale est aux côtés des
maires pour un projet d'école pour un
projet de rénovation de salle des fêtes
pour créer une piste cyclable
je pense que c'est la décentralisation
concrètes
l'équipe d'ingénierie été constitué au
départ de trois personnes
elle en compte 18 aujourd'hui et est
appelée à évoluer dans les prochaines
années
l'assainissement la vidéoprotection le
conseil juridique le conseil financier y
aurait plein d'autres choses à faire on
va essayer de grandir de consolider déjà
des communes qui sont adhérentes et puis
d'essayer de rajouter très probablement
dans les années à venir d'autres
compétences pour être au plus près des
élus
l'agencé financé à 95 % par le
département les 5% restants proviennent
des cotisations des communes adhérentes
entre 70 centimes et 1 euro par habitant
en prenant qu'à fin à ce que votre
commune a déjà sollicité un génial
oui bien sûr depuis sa création à
plusieurs reprises sur des dossiers
qu'on n'aurait pas été en capacité de
traiter parce qu'on n'a pas dans les
petites communes ma commune à 700
habitants on a très peu de services et
donc on était pas on n'est pas en
capacité de traiter des dossiers aussi
enfin parfois assez important c'est
vraiment moins là il faut saluer sont
pierre bédier 100 créateurs mais c'est
vraiment un outil mis en place par le
département qui est d'une très très
grande qualité et bon effectivement dans
la commune on a déjà cinq ou six
dossiers à curité par exemple sûr sûr
sûr l'une des uv pour pour recréer une
prairie humide il ya toute une opération
d'achat d'expropriation et c'est qu'on
n'aurait jamais été capable de mener
on est en train de travailler sur sur la
création d'une liaison d'une liaison
piétons enfin disons douce de qui va
traverser le village on a besoin d
ingénierie et puis on a un contrat rural
en cours sur trois opérations et là
encore on a on travaille avec un
technicien d'ingénierie qui nous apporte
tout son savoir faire une nous aide
aussi à retrouver à monter des dossiers
financiers c'est vraiment extrêmement
utile et c'est vraiment je crois qu'il
n'a pas d'autre c'est une des seules
n'ont en tout cas et je crois que c'est
un modèle qui sera jeu pendant les
années qui viennent va être suivie par
beaucoup d'autres
merci en tout cas bruno caffin monde est
revenu sur notre plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes donc le maire de bouaye en
vexin que vous êtes mobilisés contre un
projet de carrière dans votre commune
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation que
chez moi aussi je suis ton passe à
l'actualité en ile de france
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine avec nos
confrères de via grand paris nous
faisons le point sur l'actualité
régionale elle cette semaine était
organisée à la défense la deuxième
édition du sommet du grand paris le
débat portait notamment sur la qualité
de vie on regarde acteurs économiques
décideurs publics et élus se succèdent
pour débattre sur des thématiques
à quoi ressemblera le grand paris en
2030 ou encore le territoire fait il
face au défi de la qualité de vie autant
de questions posées qui demande des
réponses précises et qui de mieux que
les acteurs du grand paris pour y
répondre en pleine canicule il y a
d'abord la qualité de l'air liée à la
problématique des transports individuels
et collectifs
c'est devenu un enjeu de santé publique
se déplacer quotidiennement pour se
rendre au travail sans polluer et sans
perdre de temps
la mobilité est toujours au centre des
préoccupations des franciliens
quand on connaît le quotidien des des
voyageurs dont moi je suis sur leurs
gardes et depuis depuis 30 ans cet
attentat les légitimes elle est très
très ancienne et évidemment on répare
pas 30 ans d'inaction sur ces questions
là en quelques mois en 2050 750 mille
nouvelles personnes s'installeront dans
la région ile de france
la moitié est attendu dans la métropole
du grand paris parvenir à loger ces
nouveaux arrivants en évitant
l'étalement urbain
ici aussi le défi est grand pour le
territoire
on s'occupe à la fois de ce qu'on a déjà
fabriqué depuis de longues années et en
particulier dans la métropole de grand
paris puisque c'est une un tissu urbain
très anciens alors que la grande région
ile de france elles sont des villes
nouvelles qui ont été construites après
la guerre donc déjà on répare tout ce
qu'on a on a 3 millions 600 mille
logements dans la métropole du grand
paris dont dix pour cent d'entre eux
sont sous habité sous-occupés insalubre
vacants et c'est à dire trois cent
soixante mille logements
les enjeux sont de taille pour ce
territoire dont la gouvernance n'est
toujours pas tranchée en attendant la
décision de l'exécutif
la vie continue et les projets se
développent dans le grand paris un
anniversaire aujourd'hui celui du traité
de versailles le 28 juin 1919 ce traité
de la paix était signé dans la galerie
des glaces du gîte du château de vayres
c'est toute cette semaine sur tv 78 nous
avons consacré une série de reportages
sur ce thème aujourd'hui dernier volet
sur les autres traités signés après la
grande guerre dans les yvelines
marylène iapichino et aux siennes bazire
se sont intéressé de plus près au traité
de singe hermalle de saint germain en
laye et aux grands trios si les
allemands sont reçus au château de
versailles pour une première
présentation du traité le 7 mai 1919
pour les autrichiens cette même scène a
lieu au château de saint germain en laye
le 2 juin il y à toute une haie
d'honneur des dragons faire des
militaires français
il y à tous les diplomates les
journalistes etc
qu'attendent mais les deep les grands
diplomates sont déjà dans la pièce avant
que les délégués rentrer dans la petite
porte même chemin le 10 septembre pour
la signature du traité
les autrichiens passe par la petite
porte jean rapp alain 17 délégations
passe par la cour d'honneur ce sont les
vainqueurs
le vaincu l'autrichien avec ses délégués
une dizaine de personnes le 2 juin 1919
et le 10 septembre 1910 pour l'acier
passe par ici parce que c'est une
délégation de 20 que tout se déroule
dans cette salle numéro une nous
contrairement aux allemands les
autrichiens décide d'adopter une
attitude positive dans l'espoir de
pouvoir négocier le traité
la méthode ne sera pas aussi probante
puisque la méthode dure ne marche pas la
méthode sympathique à l'autrichienne ne
marche pas non plus le traité quasiment
fait quand on leur donne ce document le
de jeu au final 380 articles signés le
10 septembre à contrecoeur pour les
autrichiens qui perds ton territoire et
se retrouve des tâches et de l'allemagne
l'autriche allemande est interdite les
alliés souhaitent une république
d'autriche
ce traité on l'a même oublié en france
dans l'entre-deux-guerres
c'est lorsqu'il y a en 1938 le schuss
j'ai cherché dans la presse si on disait
qu'il y avait un traité de saint germain
en laye 5 ans minimum et bien la presse
locale petit réveil ne parle même plus
on est moins de 20 ans très du traité de
saint germain en laye comme si on avait
mauvaise conscience
d'avoir ce traité ne vend pas respecté
de ne pas avoir les moyens de le faire
respecter
face au grand reich l'attitude cordiale
autrichienne n'aura pas suffi à la
négociation mais elle entraînera une
attitude cordiale de la part de georges
clemenceau et ses alliés un honneur un
peu pour les autrichiens les autrichiens
les délégués aux tricheurs donné par
karl rahner repasseront par cet escalier
d'honneur au même moment en hongrie la
dictature bolchévique empêche les
délégués ont droit de se rendre à saint
germain en laye leur traité de paix aura
lieu un an plus tard au grand trianon à
versailles le 4 juin 1920
c'est sûrement l'un des traités qui
était le plus durement ressenti
parce que la hongrie a perdu plus de la
moitié de son territoire donc ça a été
une perte territoriale absolument énorme
à laquelle d'ailleurs je pense les
hongrois ne s'attendait pas elle perd
des terres le territoire au profit la
tchécoslovaquie au profit de la roumanie
c'est la transylvanie qui est un énorme
territoire et au profit aussi du royaume
des serbes des croates et des slovènes
qui deviendra la yougoslavie une année
est passée mais les hongrois attente la
même stratégie de négociation que les
autrichiens le démembrement de cet
empire d'autriche hongrie a abouti à la
création de nouveaux états qui ont pris
du coup part du côté des alliés et puis
il ne restait finalement que deux états
qui ont toujours été considérés comme
des ennemis l'autriche réduite à sa
partie germanophone
et puis la hongrie réduite au coeur de
la partie magyar de cet ancien pays et
donc
l'autriche et la hongrie se sont
retrouvés du côté des ennemis alors qui
eux clamait le fait qu'ils avaient été
pris dans un enfer beaucoup plus vaste
qui n'était pas responsable de des actes
de cet ancien empire
aujourd'hui il en reste deux nouveaux
états de nouvelles la nation au coeur de
l'europe et avec une une amertume
certaine de la part du peuple hongrois
face à ce démembrement de de son
territoire
une amertume pour cet ancien empire
austro hongrois qui aura sa part de
responsabilité dans le déclenchement de
la seconde guerre mondiale et bien sûr
vous pouvez retrouver notre dossier
consacré au sens du traité de versailles
sur notre site internet tv 78 points
comme voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo et merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
prochain point avec l'actualité en
direct ce sera lundi à 18 heures avec à
grégory à canal et excellent week-end à
tous
[Musique]